esta persona quiere jugar a la pelota
pero desafortunadamente como a muchos
nos ha pasado a veces cuando uno juega
la pelota le dan un pelotazo en la cara
y bueno desafortunadamente para esta
persona es una excelente oportunidad
para hablar de la relación entre el
tiempo y la fuerza e impulso momento
vamos a poner algunos números aquí
digamos que esta pelota tiene una masa
de punto dos kilogramos y va a llegar
con una velocidad de diez metros por
segundo le va a dar en la cara a esta
persona y luego va a rebotar con una
velocidad de cinco metros por segundo y
digamos que el periodo de tiempo en el
que la pelota estuvo en contacto con el
rostro de esta persona fue de punto cero
dos segundos estos son nuestros datos
con esta información podemos hacernos
todo tipo de preguntas una de ellas es
cuál es el impulso en la bola provocada
por la persona bueno
el impulso lo denominamos con la letra
jota mayúscula aunque no sé por qué ya
que impulso no tiene ninguna
vamos a poner mejor esta jota para que
se entienda bien y el impulso jota se
define como la fuerza que está actuando
en este objeto multiplicado por la
duración de tiempo que está aplicándose
esa fuerza en el objeto en otras
palabras el impulso en un objeto es
igual a su fuerza multiplicado por la
duración del tiempo que está actuando
esta fuerza podemos usar esta fórmula
para encontrar el impulso no porque
desconozco cuál es la fuerza que está
actuando en el rostro de esta persona
así que no puedo usar esta fórmula bueno
tenemos otra fórmula que podemos usar y
esta es la fórmula del impulso neto es
decir todas las fuerzas de impulso que
están actuando en un objeto por ejemplo
el de esta bola va a ser igual al cambio
en el momento de este objeto como el
cambio de momento en esta pelota si
podemos encontrar el cambio en el
momento de esta pelota podremos
encontrar el impulso neto en este
ya que estamos hablando del impulso neto
podemos decir que es igual a la fuerza
neta que está actuando en este objeto
multiplicada por la duración de tiempo
que están actuando estas fuerzas y a
veces a algunas personas les es difícil
recordar todo esto a mis estudiantes les
gusta aprender se está imaginando que
esto es hub fat este es un buen amónico
para recordar esto have fat de manera
que el impulso neto es igual al cambio
en el momento y es igual a la fuerza
neta por la duración del tiempo vamos a
hacerlo aquí desconozco cuáles son las
fuerzas pero si puede encontrar el
momento ya que conozco las velocidades
vamos a escribirlo por acá sabemos que
el cambio en el momento es igual al
momento final menos el momento inicial
cuál es la rapidez en el momento final
es cinco metros por segundo así que este
momento va a ser igual a la masa
por la rapidez final menos el momento
inicial que es ve por la rapidez inicial
y esto es igual a mi masa que es de
punto 2 kilogramos multiplicada por mi
rapidez final que es de 5 metros por
segundo es cuando rebotó en el rostro y
va a ser positivo porque se dirige hacia
la derecha
- esta misma masa punto 2 kilogramos por
la rapidez inicial que era cuando se
dirigía al rostro de esta persona 10
metros por segundo iba a tener signo
negativo porque va hacia la izquierda
esto es por menos 10 metros por segundo
y bueno aquí debo aclarar algo yo les
estaba mencionando que esto es la
rapidez pero no el momento es un vector
entonces vamos a estar hablando de
velocidad que también son vectores y con
esto tenemos que asegurarnos de indicar
una dirección y es por eso que le
ponemos signos la dirección que va hacia
la derecha va a ser positiva y la
dirección que va hacia la izquierda va a
ser
y esto es un error muy común poner aquí
por ejemplo directamente el 10 y no
dedicar su dirección tenemos que indicar
la dirección porque estos son vectores
entonces esto es velocidad final este
vector de 5 metros por segundo con
dirección a la derecha positivo y esta
es la velocidad inicial que es de 10
metros por segundo con dirección hacia
la izquierda y le indicamos con el signo
negativo si no incluimos bien los signos
vamos a tener una respuesta diferente
así que hay que tener cuidado y si hago
estos cálculos me va a quedar aquí un
kilogramo metro por segundo menos menos
dos kilogramos metros por segundo
finalmente esto me va a dar
kilogramos metros por segundo positivo y
este es el impulso y tiene sentido ya
que el impulso es positivo y la
dirección del impulso que es un vector
va a ser la misma dirección que la
fuerza neta qué dirección va a ser esta
pues vemos que nuestro rostro le dio una
fuerza a la pelota y esta fuerza tenía
una dirección hacia la derecha es por
eso que este impulso en la pelota va
hacia la derecha es positivo el impulso
en el rostro de la persona va hacia la
izquierda pero el impulso en la bola por
la persona va hacia la derecha ya que
inicialmente la pelota iba hacia la
izquierda y después se le dio un impulso
hacia la derecha y es por eso que este
impulso tiene una dirección positiva
y si ustedes han prestado atención me
pueden decir a ver un momento aquí lo
único que hicimos es encontrar el cambio
en el momento de la pelota y al hacer
esto encontramos el impulso neto en la
bola en otras palabras el impulso de
todas las fuerzas actuando en la pelota
pero en la pregunta nos están pidiendo
el impulso de una sola fuerza el
ocasionado por el rostro de la persona y
acaso no hay otras fuerzas que estén
afectando a esta pelota acá solo tenemos
la fuerza de gravedad y si es así no
deberíamos tomar en cuenta estas otras
fuerzas también y la respuesta es no
en realidad no y una de las razones es
que aquí nos están dando solamente la
velocidad horizontal estos diez metros
por segundo están en la dirección x y
estos cinco metros por segundo también
están en la dirección horizontal así que
si tomo la velocidad final en x y la
velocidad inicial mx
estoy encontrando la diferencia del
momento en la dirección horizontal y al
hacer eso estoy encontrando el impulso
neto en la dirección x así que aquí sólo
hubo una fuerza horizontal que es la de
este rostro en la pelota que fue hacia
la derecha y en efecto tenemos la fuerza
de gravedad que va hacia abajo pero esta
fuerza de gravedad no agrega ni quita
impulso en la dirección horizontal trata
de agregar impulso en la dirección
vertical en la dirección de iu va a
agregar un componente de la velocidad
pero hacia abajo pero esto no lo vamos a
considerar aquí solamente vamos a
considerar los componentes horizontales
de la velocidad y cuánta velocidad
agrega la gravedad verticalmente pues
típicamente no es mucha en esta
situación porque el periodo de tiempo en
el que está actuando esta fuerza es muy
pequeño y el peso de esta pelota
comparada con la fuerza que este rostro
está ejerciendo en ella
el peso típicamente va a ser más pequeño
que la fuerza de esta colisión y es por
eso que en estos problemas de colisión
típicamente ignoramos la gravedad
encontramos el impulso neto en la
dirección horizontal y ya que el impulso
de este rostro es el único que está
actuando en la dirección horizontal
este es el impulso que nos están
preguntando resolvamos un problema más 9
es la fuerza promedio en el rostro de la
persona provocada por la bola bueno
conocemos el impulso neto en la pelota y
con esto podremos encontrar la fuerza
neta en la bola ya que ahora puedo usar
esta relación así que yo sé que el
impulso neto en la dirección x en esta
bola es igual a la fuerza neta en la
dirección horizontal en esta bola
multiplicada por la duración del tiempo
en el que se ejerció esta fuerza así que
el impulso neto es igual a tres
kilogramos metros por segundo y esto es
igual a la fuerza neta en la dirección x
que desgraciadamente fue proporcionada
por el rostro de esta persona y
multiplicada por el intervalo de tiempo
que duró esta fuerza que es de 0.02
segundos o lo que es lo mismo de 20
milisegundos ahora sí despejo mi fuerza
neta en la dirección x me va a quedar
que es igual a tres kilogramos metros
por segundo entre 0.0 dos segundos y nos
va a quedar que esto es igual a 150
newtons
esta es la fuerza neta en la pelota en
la dirección x y tenemos una cantidad
positiva lo que tiene sentido ya que el
rostro de esta persona proporcionó una
fuerza positiva a la pelota ya que va
hacia la derecha así que tenemos una
fuerza positiva y el impulso debe tener
la misma dirección que la fuerza así que
esta es la fuerza neta de hecho aquí
tengo un pequeño rosito esto es la
fuerza neta en la dirección horizontal
ejercida por el rostro de la persona en
la pelota pero no tengo que nos
preguntan cuál es la fuerza promedio la
fuerza promedio en el rostro de la
persona por la bola del rostro en la
bola y ustedes pueden decirme hay cara y
voy a tener que comenzar todo de nuevo
pero no aquí despejamos para la fuerza
equivocada pero tenemos suerte ya que la
tercera ley de newton dice
que la fuerza del rostro en la bola es
igual pero con sentido opuesto a la
fuerza de la bola en el rostro aquí
tenemos la fuerza del rostro en la bola
esto significa que la fuerza de la bola
en el rostro tiene la misma magnitud
pero va a tener la dirección opuesta
entonces va a tener la misma magnitud
que está a 150 minutos pero va a estar
en la dirección opuesta es decir va a
tener un signo negativo así que aquí
vamos a tener una fuerza de menos 150
newtons en el rostro por la pelota en
resumen el impulso para una fuerza
individual está dada por esta fórmula el
impulso de una fuerza es igual a dicha
fuerza multiplicada por el periodo de
tiempo en el que se está ejerciendo esa
fuerza y si estamos hablando de la
fuerza neta en cierta dirección durante
cierto intervalo de tiempo estaremos
encontrando el impulso neto en esa
dirección y resulta que esto es igual al
en el momento en esta dirección en otras
palabras si tenemos un impulso neto en
una dirección también vamos a tener un
cambio en el momento en esa misma
dirección tendrán la misma magnitud y
una forma de recordar esto con un de
mónico es el de rabat no tengo idea qué
significa esta palabra
pero me ayuda a recordar que el impulso
neto es igual al cambio en el momento y
a su vez es igual a la fuerza neta
multiplicada por el intervalo de tiempo
en el que ocurre esta fuerza y
finalmente recuerden que cuando ocurre
en todas estas colisiones vamos a tener
fuerzas iguales pero en dirección
opuesta entre los objetos que están
participando en esta colisión